Mr Wonderful here in this video I'm
going to share the brutal truths you
need to accept to live your best life
[Music]
number one
your appearance how you look how other
people see you you should start worrying
about your parents when you're in your
early 20s do you get enough sleep you
stay out of the sun I'm not saying you
shouldn't get vitamin D but if you're
going to get baked in the sun put on
some sunscreen think about your skin
what's it going to look like when you're
50 and 60 years old you start take care
of yourself early you're going to look
great don't eat crap food sure it's fun
to eat a burger and all that stuff
that's fine but think about what you're
eating lots of fruits and vegetables
have a balanced diet it's not crazy
everybody tells you this but it really
adds up over the long term that's very
important take care of your body it'll
take care of you yeah some exercise is
going to hurt you either that's why I'm
walking I could get one of these golf
carts but I don't want to be lazy I want
to walk get my steps in I try and do 10
000 steps a day every phone will tell
you how many steps you're walking try
for ten thousand twelve thousand a day
very healthy for you long term there's
no better way to start them with today's
sponsor teas Hanley guys I don't just
partner with any company I have to use
the products I don't endorse just
anything I've used teach Hanley products
for years now and I truly believe that
they'll have a positive impact on your
appearance and how you feel tiege Hanley
simplifies the process of taking care of
your skin they provide you with all the
products you need and nothing you don't
I recommend you start with their level
one system which comes with all the
basics a daily face wash and exfoliating
scrub a dub dub an AM moisturizer with
SPF 20 I use that every day that keeps
the sun off the Dome very handy in
protecting that Dome of desire you don't
want that birth by the sun I'll tell you
that and a PM moisturizer and because
she's handling is sponsoring today's
video they're offering my viewers a
great deal just click the link and that
description the first link in the
description and you get 30 off your
first box plus a free gift don't miss
out on this amazing deal click that link
and get started today and take care of
your own Dome
[Music]
that's it okay number two start
investing now
now not savings a savings account is not
the same as investing investing means
you put it into the market which gives
you eight to ten percent a year over
your entire lifetime so if you have your
average salary of fifty eight thousand
dollars and you try and get fifteen
percent of it and put it away even into
a market index an ETF or something it'll
grow with you by the way look at this
crafty see I'm conscious of what's here
I want to eat healthy I'm not going to
eat a lot of sugar I could but I'm just
saying No No Nanette this place is where
everybody hangs out during the shoot get
a little energy but think about what
you're eating eat an apple you know that
kind of thing
another very important point is you want
to build your knowledge you want to
build what you enjoy learning about you
constantly want to be finding out new
information and that's why it's
important to find something in life that
you want to work on that you're
passionate about because you want to
learn more that's the whole idea so if
you love what you do and you want to
become better at it you never stop
learning you want to build that
knowledge base up that's the strategy
become an expert in your field and well
known for that matter and the more time
passes the more you learn the more you
actually educate because you want to
listen you don't want to miss these last
few points they really matter set a goal
and achieve it set another goal achieve
that set another goal achieve it do it
in steps
and your overall goal set yourself free
if you're an entrepreneur it's not about
the pursuit of money that's greed
nothing to do with it it's the pursuit
of personal freedom you want to pursue
personal freedom to have control over
your time later in life and provide for
your family of course but it doesn't
mean you have to have a flashy car you
have to be you know covered in diamonds
that's nothing to do with it
having control of your own time is
really in my view the definition of
success and you have to pursue that and
of course it involves Financial Freedom
but not the greed of money
pursuing money just for the sake of
having it you'll never get there that's
trouble is you never have enough
but in life you don't need that much
once you decide what your lifestyle
should be you build it for that keep
your Connections in other words your
network of people stay close with them
in your life you'll meet thousands of
people but only 20 of them are going to
become your close friends work on those
relationships make sure that you keep in
touch it's good for business too but
also your family spend enough time with
them now if you're an entrepreneur
you're going to be working your ass off
I know that you don't have to tell me
that but I stay in touch with my family
I stay close with my friends and I
nurture those relationships you know I
work harder today than I ever have
because I like to work
the pursuit I wanted I enjoy supporting
entrepreneurs I enjoy doing Shark Tank I
do the things I care about
that's what you want for yourself too